have many Benny Applebaum even if only
virtually present us tell us about
advisor verify approver games and the
the relation to information theoretic
photography
thank you
um
so so first let me thank the organizers
like I looked at some of the videos
there online and it looks like a very
amazing event so uh you know thanks for
organizing this Workshop although I
thought okay I couldn't make it
and
um
so this is the first time that I'm going
to give this day that I'm giving this
talk so you know please comment or feel
free to
um to interact or interact during the
talk you know whenever you have a
question I'll be happy to hear the
comments also by email after that if you
want
and this is a joint profit my student of
that name
and the reason that I highlighted here
the word assumptions is that one of the
points that I want to make so so this
question this talk has more questions
than answers and one of the points that
I want to make is that for some parts of
cryptography it's not even clear that we
need assumptions
um enlightened I thought if I get
started from stock
is is the question you know under which
assumptions a cryptography really need
to say
this is for the Meta Meta complexity
Workshop
so I'm already ready for this so just to
restore this point let me like take a
look at the world
and
um right I mean I think that the as far
as I could see my gaps like we talked a
lot about all these uh areas
I mean you know we can discuss whether
we should put nisk in crypto menu or
minicrypt and
um and whether they I guess a pestilent
even exist and so on
but now that I think as far as I could
see uh we didn't even talk like during
the swap shop and typically also in
cryptography conferences we don't really
talk about algorithmica
and we do not talk about it for a good
reason
right I mean we have this kind of a meta
theorem that says that you know
interesting crypto really needs a
one-way functions by starting with the
work of impal De lubi and we have many
many versions of this steel and that
were pulled in different contexts
and indeed you can see in this map right
is also known as the great Sandy waste
and the deadly desert or the impossible
desert and so on and so forth so it's
really a Boeing place to be
a but I want to to mention that we have
some constructions same Miniclip for
example in a garbage circuits that we do
not know whether they really belong to
manicure or actually they belong to uh
into algorithmica another example even
in cryptomania I'll talk about it later
this notion of 16 secret sharing so we
know how to build it in this land but
it's not even clear that we need any
assumption for it and there are other
examples even if in a of dystopia
so I'm not going to question this
theorem but I just want to make the
point that we do want to have a football
for this theorem of some of the
Primitives that we're in so there's
still open questions even in this domain
okay which seems to be like close I
don't know since the 90s I guess
okay so let me be a more concrete
so let's start with private information
with privilege so we heard about it in
Daniel stock and right I mean we have a
client we have a server who holds the
database and this client wants to access
the database without revealing the the
location right
and then I'm going to think about like a
single round schemes
and it will be convenient for me to
think of this database as a tool stable
of a function so this is capital n Bits
which means that it represents an NBA
Boolean function
and since we are going to talk about the
information theoretic variance of this
problem okay so accordingly I didn't say
accordingly the index is just an Ambit
string right it's an index in this coj
tools table
and since we are in the information
theoretic setting I'm going to assume
that there are several syllables
where each server holds a copy of this
function f and this client is allowed to
access each of them separately
and when we talk about privacy we mean
that the query say to the first
server is distributed independently of X
right so this client has coins and if we
restrict our view only to the first
query do the first server we cannot tell
anything about this stream right so this
is the standard notion of policy
good so
I want to focus on the communication
right I don't care about computation
here
and we can ask can you get a poly and
communication not that this is like
lowercase n so this is like poly logging
the size of the database
and to make my life easier this formula
open perspective I'm going to strike
this problem to the case whether I have
only a constant number of servers and
the answers from the servers are just a
constant or say even single bit
and this setting is known to be
essentially equivalent to the to the
case of local decodable codes which are
a binary okay and I'm going to think
about the question of communication here
translates very nicely to the question
of the the length of such codes the best
possible length
so what do you know about this question
so the lower bound is uh as all the low
Bonds in the stock is going to be fairly
pathetic right I mean so n plus Omega of
n so this L is living right I mean
because we know that you have to kind of
communicate at least and bids because
your input otherwise you know the answer
is not well defined
so an nptel outbound here is Trivial and
we can get a linear or an additional
linear amount of bits a event where the
constant really depends on the scale the
number of servers
and although this law about this
pathetic it's highly non-trivial to
poverty
and in fact in the upcoming the stock
there is a new result that proves the 3M
Global so there is very special case of
three server single bidences so even
this thing is a extremely complicated
and requires some a new combinatorial
insights
good so that's the lower bound what's
the upper bound
so the upper bound is a sub exponential
right it's 2 to the square root of N and
this is based on the matching virtual
approach it was introduced by a Canon
right
so that's the best upper bound that's
the best low band and there we see that
there's Gap and we cannot rule out the
poly solution
I should mention that if you are willing
to assume to make computational
assumptions right to will execute into
computational then we actually get a
polyle a polyane solution or poly login
the size of the database this is the
gilboy right just based on a sufficient
list of one-way functions
okay
but again it's not clear whether this
one functions are really needed I mean
we in a sense we kind of throw in a
computational gadget without knowing
whether you know fencing combinatorial
ideals can actually solve the problem
without using a complexity theoretic
tools
um okay let's move on to the next
primitive
this is a generalized SQL sharing
so if here our client holds a secret
it's going to distribute the secret
across these servers so we have n
servers this time not a constant number
of servers
I want to make sure that there are some
authorized sets that should be able to
recover the secret given their shares
but unauthorized sets should not play
should not should learn nothing about
the secret
I think the way we specify Auto as an
unauthorized set is based on this
function right so we can think about the
input to the function as a subset and
the function test model that is set is
authorized or not and since the subset
of a non-authorized set is also not
authorized in a superset of an
authorized set must be authorized we can
assume that this function is one
okay
so again we can ask what is the best
possible solution and here I'm going to
measure again I don't care about the
computational complexity I'm going to
measure the quality of the solution as
the size of the maximal show
and
we can ask can I get a put in a shelf
size
so here the lower bank is not even
linear it's n over log n right due to
cylinders
and the best type of bound is currently
1.5 to the end so for a long time it was
2 to the end then uh
how to quick we're able to push this a
little bit and then by sequence after a
sequence of work this was shaped to a a
3 over 2 to the n okay this is jointly
with the other same student tool with
the cutoff of this paper
so again
almost linear low bound exponential
upper bound
and we do not know where the tool is and
again if we throw in our fancy
cryptographic tools we have this new
result
uh with almost
and that gives us a solution based on
Cell explanations
so we can get this kind of solution if
we are willing to make in this case
cryptomania type assumptions and again
it's not clear that this is
I mean it's not it's not going to kill
that one-way function even maybe we can
do this
okay
good questions remarks
let's move to the third primitive
so this is a fully decomposable analyze
according and this is a also known as
the goblin schemes or Garbage circuits
and the private simultaneous message
protocols it has many names so
randomizing polynomials
and here again we have n servers
each server is going to hold a single
bit
okay
in addition these servers are going to
be to have access to random strings
a joint line of sync and based on these
inputs I'd say the first server looks
like it's input the random thing and it
computes a is a message and sends it to
the client
now the client sees all these messages
yes
someone sneezed okay I was hoping for a
question I can answer it
is this for like a like worse so like we
also found like the worst case say
choice of like have yes yes I'm assuming
that this is kind of I want a solution
that works so every F so in a sense this
is one's case level DFS very good I
don't push change
okay so let me Define this model so
again so the first bug looks at X1 the
random string the function is public in
this case and they send the randomized
message and this client who sees these
messages but doesn't see the inputs of
the a string should be able to compute
the value of the function in the point x
but nothing else
okay so this is the engine we couldn't
find the privacy in a in a very a
natural way
so again we can ask can we get a poly
and uh right and then I'm going to
measure the the maximal communication
complexity over this Channel and I can
ask can we get to pull in a solution
and again here the lower bound is a very
weak and login basically this is a
martial in France
foreign
so again huge gap
and the effect here I don't even know um
how to do it computationally without
throwing in some really like crazy
Machinery like ideal obsessions or
things like this right so you know I I I
don't know this is uh this lives in a
fantasy land or something like it's not
right now
um
good
like every like a access party
this is also like a worst case over like
a access party
like it was good for the word what about
the functions but it's not one of these
are General functions
it's like I mean this uh shower like
secret sharing like Sorry probably this
is the question about like the last last
slides that like this
uh secretaries game like over here
like a
uh it's like access it's like authored
like this like structure of this like
authorization sound like right we're
considering like arbitrary General
life okay
I uh also write authoritization like
it's a structure or
that means it is
our access Park yes let me let me say a
few more words and then if the question
is still relevant I'll try to answer it
right so so let's let's look at let's
try to compare these models
just a quick different question so on
the previous side why did you say
counter computation like why does it own
the Yahoo circuit solve the problem is
it because this is an arbitrary function
it doesn't have if you have a small
circuit show you can solve it a a using
government circuits and even the you
know I don't know whether any one-way
function is necessary for wife or
gobbling the circuit but this is the
whole talk
all my functions are kind of represented
by tooth table
and I could I could actually give the
talk also in a variable functions rlp
and and I think that they are kind of in
a sense the current setting where we
talk about two steps is more basic and
therefore I I attack this but uh you'll
see at the end that there are some
interesting questions also for for this
the variant functions have efficient
representation okay
sorry I might have not just understood
this model so where um so there's like
some function that's known in advance
and where did the servers get X how do
they decide the X so we need to think
about an external party who publishes if
so everyone knows if you know
okay and the and this outside entity uh
did this this external entity also gives
us gives the servers the inputs
just like in a you know when you want to
encrypt someone gives you the input to
the user or someone gives you in an NPC
someone gives the input to the puppies
results fit in here uh does it just is
it just like not as optimal as like the
computational KRS that we have because I
just I'm just kind of wondering is it
here
here I don't know how to use to get
something again in this world okay
okay maybe it's possible this is a very
good question but we don't know how to
do it
so let me try to put the models one next
to each other and try to see for a
second how they relate to each other
so in a sense there are very different
models
so you know let's let's start from the
last one right I mean here all the
information flows from the servers to
the clients
and we want to kind of keep the inputs
of the servers protected and the
function is public right I mean everyone
knows the function
in this model actually the servers have
no input right I mean the information
flow from the client to the servers
right and the function is public but now
it kind of indicates a a what are the
the access structures that you know that
should be able to recover the the output
but as opposed to kind of here we have
some sort of computation over the
private data here we don't compute
anything over private data by the
function just tell us which parties
should be able to recover the value
and here this is completely different
story right I mean here we have a
bi-directional communication so you know
the information flows in both directions
uh the function is private in this case
right I mean decline does not know the
function if he knows the function then
you know it doesn't have to communicate
with the servers at all
and we want to kind of keep the privacy
of this input X but once we put the
communication complexity a kind of a
requirement but also it also means that
in a sense we somewhat hide some
information about this function as well
right so we have two you know two two
sides of uh of uh hiding in this case
but it's in all the other cases we have
only one-sided in a sense right either
we want to protect the client or we want
to protect the servers and you know you
see the information flow it's very
different so this seems to be like three
different games
ER in all these cases we have upper
bounds which are either exponential or
sad exponential in the case of Bill
and the low bounds of the almost linear
Hydro linear in the case of Bill right
so very a big gaps
and
um
and you know we are not well maybe some
of us are used to seeing these kind of
big gaps like I mean when we talk about
let's say circuit load balance but here
I like the case of complexity Theory we
don't even have like non-constructive
lowdowns so you know take the function
at random or use the worst case function
or whatever we still don't know how to
pull anything
and another annoying thing is that we do
not have General rejection between these
problems so you know we know that the MP
is likely to oh we believe that MP is
different than p and we know that it's
going to be very hard to prove it but at
least we know that all the MP heart
problems are equivalent right up to
polynomial reductions and then we don't
even have an equivalent so we cannot
kind of point out to a single assumption
that the
um that implies the how to install these
kind of things we can make different
assumption for each of these planets
why should we care
um so there are several reasons
these are the basic questions and they
typically give like the solutions that
we do have are actually very very simple
and clean in some sense in some ways
scenarios they're even more efficient
than the the computational solutions
also these kind of questions kind of
appear also in advanced Primitives so
many Advanced Primitives of just you
know a complicated versions of these
simple Primitives I could write you a
logger list
and the hope is that once we get good
understanding of the of the ideals of
the problems that that appear in this
level will also have better ideas of how
to solve the problems in the more
advanced level and in fact I can say
that the RSA results that I've just
mentioned indeed it is based on some
insights that were developing while
working on the information field and
take a variant of the problem
and there are many other examples for
this kind of methodology
and finally this kind of you know these
gaps actually highlight some some basic
things that we do not understand so in a
sense it's a
it's easier for us to jump and throw in
our fancy computational assumptions but
we should remember that you know in some
in some cases we don't even know whether
these things are really inherent and you
know you shouldn't use like mobile you
shouldn't use a prf when you can use
like a pairwise independent cache
function like the same thing here I mean
these heavy animals if they are not
justified you shouldn't use them or at
least we should know that they that are
not necessary for these tests
good
so hopefully I convinced you
any question yes please
encryption of me we do know that we only
care about function that have short
representation as a circuit
representation
two two so first of all as I said that
um I said previously so I could phrase
all these questions there for you know
for efficiency computable functions for
example for efficiently computable
functions monotone functions we have
secret joint based on monoclean silica
based on a one-way functions and we
don't know how to achieve it information
theoretically this is still open
similarly uh here uh I mean we have
Yahoo circuit as Daniel mentioned but we
do not know whether they could do it
information theoretically
and the reason that I'm looking at this
General function is that typically when
you solve if you make progress for kind
of Truth tables you can lift it up and
actually get some problems in the
circuit model of advanced models and I
think that the two-stable setting is
this kind in a sense is cleaner because
one of the things that kind of make the
problems in when you look at the more
advanced Primitives
when the one of the things that I think
make the problem harder is the fact that
you look at the circuits right I mean
you look at computational efficiency on
the efficient computation and this is an
object that we don't understand right I
mean computationally efficient
computation is is a mystery
uh and and do I look and and when we
look at this kind of uh versions I kind
of throw away all the computational
requirements or the computational
restrictions uh I don't have to
understand circuits in order to answer
this question either in affirmative or
to the negative this is all the things
good no more comments please
okay
[Music]
um
how much time do I have by the way
five to ten minutes okay
let me try to actually tell you what we
do and give you some hints about it
so we introduced the new hypothesis
and we show that it actually implies a
single hypothesis
all these Primitives
you'll see in a minute but this kind of
new operators is uh kind of is related
to a classical subject in computer
science the space query trade officers
that you can get but it's kind of the
The Twist is that we take it into the
interactive setting
and they by using this kind of tool we
also get new insights about the
differences between these Primitives
we can unify some of the existing lower
bounds
and we can also show that some logons
cannot be unified right we need some
sort of separations
so let me tell you what's the new notion
so this is the standard setting of
interactive proofs like we have a
verified we have approval of the prover
claims that f of x equals to one and the
verifier should either be accept or
reject and I'm going to make the
following twist so the verifier does not
see the function
okay there is an advisor there is a
third entity an advisor that wants to
help the verifier this is a trusted
advisor the advisor gets the function f
he generates an advice
then the verifier gets X the advisor
dies after it generates the advice the
verifier gets the the input X and then
based on this input and the advice you
should make a single round of
interaction with the approver and decide
whether to accept Origins okay so that's
the the model
and some defaults so all parties of
computationally unbounded and for this
reasoning as long as I'm keeping this
default I cannot talk about the fixed F
because if the function is a fixed then
the verifier can just compute it by
himself
okay I'm going to assume completeness
constant soundness and I'm going to
assume that the advice is a one-time
advice so you cannot use it over where
many inputs
so this is the model and the goal is to
minimize the communication right the sum
of the views
so let's play with this model a little
bit
so first of all if I throw away the
approval what do I get
it
let me assume that you said the answer
because I can't hear any results so
um we get a one-way communication
complexity on the light one particles
the other particles X and there is just
a unidirectional communication and we
know for this model that there is an
exponential though and that's actually
easy to pull
what happens if we switch from a general
approval to a trusted proverb that gives
us a an access to F puncture the context
so we are not allowed to ask about the
point x what we are allowed to ask on
any other points and we get the sales
Black Box model and then again we have
exponential logo
whatever what happens if we require the
a to be reusable
then this time to be
closely related to memory
checking and again in this model uh
there is a law about which is
exponential
on the other hand what happens if we
relax the model and allow more
interaction
so it turns out that this model
corresponds to non-uniform delegation
this is in the model paper
in some of the Hidden sections and there
they show actually that you can get
quality and communication in the
kwazuliar or a number of rounds or more
generally if f is a DDF S size the
circuit then you can get this then the
communication is polynomial in the depth
and logarithmic in the poliographic in
the size of the circuit and this is also
the complexity of the verify right so
this is kind of a non-trivial statement
good so what happens when we have a
single round can we get poly and
communication
so the answer is yes Danny yes what was
the reusable point about a whether what
do you mean by reusable
reusable I mean that you can get a
single advice and then the sound
remains valid even if kind of the
approval and the verifier use kind of
play the game again and again with
different X's
so in a sense like the advice is a kind
of generated with Randomness and this
Randomness can be used only once like
otherwise it's kind of being leaked to
improve
okay
so here's a solution with poly and
communication right I mean the advisor
defines the multinational extension of F
and it gives one point of this
multilineal extension one random point
and now we can basically sample a random
line embed this plant this point in a
random location get the answers check
consistency with the advice and
interpolated by it okay and then and we
get some use of one minus one over n but
we can repeat and we'll get the overall
communication is going to be polynomial
right so now that here this deposit
speaks a lot
so since I want to prove lower bounds
let me restrict the approval to be
electronic so the prover can sense only
a constant number of bits
and here comes the hypothesis we assume
that the hypoten says that this
equivalent kvp
cannot have polynomial complexity they
have super polynomial complexity
and the feeling which is really simple
to go over and show you the proof in a
in like one minute
any polynomial solution for any of the
above Primitives will imply approval
iconic AVP with polynomial complexity
and this means that if you believe in
the hypothesis then you'll get a super
polynomial low Bound for pale
signaturing and the decomposable
randomizer
so the poof idea is kind of based on
this Paradigm of translating a secrecy
to soundness and it appeals in many many
works I think that you can even trace it
back to the original paper on the
interactive proofs so the transformation
is not going to be very exciting let me
show it to you
so let's start with pill
so we know that this field uh let's
let's let you know by q1 the query that
the the client sends it to the server
and by R1 the answer
so the advisor is going to sample one
bill query and one plaster and remember
that you know when we look at the single
queries distribution is independent of
the input so this can be done ahead of
time now the verifier sees X can kind of
sample this queries conditioned on the
original query that was sent by the
advisor get the answer from the
electronic proverb and then check
consistency widget
right and this is in fact the previous
example they showed was this a special
case of this transformation
what happened with secret sharing again
very simply so we have this signature
and scheme so that vessel is going to
give us all these shares and the secret
the verifier is going to send the
sequence the shares that correspond to
the input X the electronic power should
be able to recover the secret and the
verify except if you know if they
approve the detected properly
now I want to point out some Super
Simple Songs is immediate you know
I want to point out that here in this
case we have a one bit answer
the vertig depends only on the advice
and on the answer but it's independent
of x
okay
and the query itself has a very nice
simple structure it's decomposable
vitamin so you know each block that I'm
going to send this depends on a single
input bit of X it's also one of them in
the sense that if I'm looking at a NX
which is larger than this the original X
and I will I'm going to send more
information
actually we have to Define monotonous
DNA it's likely a more careful way but
so now it's okay
so we have this signature that implies
all this thing and let me mention that
the
[Music]
um
when we have all these properties we can
actually talk about the single function
if now it makes sense and the the
question is well defined
similarly I'm not going to show you this
transformation this is an exercise but
here you'll see that we get the first
three properties the composability one
bit answer input independent verdict but
now we don't get monotonicity instead we
get this input hiding property which
means they can run this interaction
without letting the approval know what
to X is so for the purpose of soundness
I can assume that they put on those X
but for a like an honest proof that I
can actually hide a a X on the proven
um good so this gives us some kind of
way to compare between these Primitives
right you see that peer gives us an AVP
without any additional properties
and this kind of means it in a sense
maybe a bill is easier to achieve right
because it implies less restricted avps
and it is based on the current balance
that we have vitamin the peer is the to
the swell then all these things are
exponential in the end
also if you look at these properties you
know there's a missing a a particle here
right I mean there should be some
primitive that implies all this thing
which only the first three properties
and indeed you can fill this block by
using what's the sometimes Cloud
condition and the social sequence
so do I have two minutes what's uh how
are we doing with time
yeah
two minutes
so
what happens can we only find lower
bounds so we can prove very simple
counting based lower bounds they
basically say that if the advisor sends
a bits and the over computation is taken
from a class G then a Times log J is at
least a 2 to the n and this implies some
very very weak General so some very very
weak lobands of the general thing which
may basically breaks whenever B is the n
Beats
but just by using this uh simple lay low
bump we can actually recover existing
load bands in all these domains so at
least counting base load bounds can be
induced by by this General primitive
it looks sorry
what about the best known lower bounds
so in the secretary world the best known
lower bound is due to Silas and use some
silver some complexity measure that is
introduced by CMS in the decomposable
randomizer coding wall the best no bank
is the based on natural products
complexity measure and it would be very
nice to unify these things but we can
show that they cannot be refined
in particular we can we come up with a
function for which it has a maximum
almost maximum same as a complexity
measure but there's very cheap CDs and
therefore chip a AVP in fact if we
allows to use the partial functions then
it can be even linear so this is a
quadratic separation which is the
maximum layer that you would hope for
also here same thing I mean we can come
up with a function which has a high
complexity measure under this measure
but very low complexity measure
according to series
let me conclude so all these basic
information theoretic primitive they
look so different but they all kind of
imply that you can decompose a
computation into an online and offline
parts
we introduce this new model a single
hypothesis that implies
the transformation themselves are kind
of a simple but the main I think
interesting part is the definition of
this model
some of the existing lower bounds you
also get some separations
as I already mentioned in the future it
will be interesting to scale down these
things to pay and interesting questions
about this this thing that I don't have
time to watch
and more generally
come up with a more maybe condition a
low bounce or at least relate them to
where existing questions
thanks
really interesting uh one question
another quick question
maybe let's ask
then in the other direction so so this
new model can be used to unify lower
bounds but it does not serve as a
barrier right because you don't need to
full blog on this model
the other direction a common ancestor
will be Primitives that services
so let me give you a common ancestor I'm
not sure but I think that the most uh
easier challenge okay in this domain
that we don't know how to solve is a
falsidious that they didn't even Define
prove that the the messages should be
super constant right we do not know that
right I mean so the other things we
could prove kind of linear lower bounds
there even a
the concept is open and this is an
intriguing question I'm not sure how
hard it is but well now we couldn't do
it that's kind of the the immediate
challenge
yeah quick question everyone
is there some dream version of a locally
decodable code that will surprise to
that like a binary
result
whenever I say peer you can think about
local decodable codes I said polynomial
think about quasi polynomials
is a binary alphabet
okay
thanks again
for those who Miss